okay let's start class so um let us
summarize and review where we are so far
in the story so um there are three major
interest forces that are pushing the
United States towards war with
Iran um the first is the Israel
Lobby remember that the Israel Lobby is
composed of both Jew Jewish interest as
well as Christian interests right
representing the Jewish interest is
something called
APAC uh and they have a membership of
about a
100,000 but they're very wealthy there
are many billionaires in this group so
this group has Financial power in fact
APAC is considered the second most
powerful lobbying organization in in the
United States the first is um the
pensioners okay there's about 30 million
of them um and their lobbying
organization is the most powerful but
APAC is second but also in the Israel
Lobby are the Christian Zionist right so
for example the organization uh
Christians United for Israel has 7
million
people um in its membership so together
the Christian Zionist and APAC um are
extremely powerful force in government
and they want a war in the middle ease
in order to advance Israel's
interest also remember that America is
now addicted to Empire because Empire
represents easy money all money has to
be uh channeled through the
US and so there are many people in the
US who just make make basically make
their money by speculating on money okay
so for example Wall Street and that has
made Wall Street extremely powerful uh
right now in US
politics and the third um force is Saudi
Arabia um remember that in our
discussion of Saudi Arabia we learned
that the major conflict in the Middle
East is actually not between Israel and
Iran but between Saudi Arabia
and
Iran for Israel Iran is a security
threat because it it supports hasah and
Hamas but for Saudi
Arabia um Iran represents a threat to
its very existance okay so Saudi Arabia
must resolve the Iran
problem soon right now how these three
forces manifest themselves is uh through
Trump okay so basically Trump is their
champion and
privately um there's a man named Jared
Kushner who is Trump's son-in-law he's
married to um Trump's fa daughter um
Ivanka Trump okay and Char Jerry
Kushner happens to be very good friends
with both Benjamin
nanyu who is of Israel as well as
Muhammad bin Salon who was the leader of
Saudi Arabia now uh Jer kushner's father
tus Kushner was a very prominent uh
sponsor of APAC in fact when Benjamin
Nan yahu comes to State United States he
lives with the kushna family so one
night uh Benjamin natany had to stay in
Jer crusher's bedroom and Jer kusher had
to sleep in the in the uh basement okay
that's how close they are and Jared
Kushner is friendly with MBS the leader
of Saudi Arabia so friendly that when
Jer Kushner started a private Equity
Fund Saudi Arabia invested two billion
dollars okay so through jar Kushner uh
these three forces are able to exert
influence on Trump as we also discussed
it's very likely that Trump will become
president of the United States again um
um in November and he will pick Nikki
Haley as his
VP and that means that Nikki Hy will be
the one in the Trump White House pushing
for war against um Iran as we discussed
uh niiki heli makes most of her money
from the um Israel Lobby okay the
anti-iran
lobby we know from the first Trump
Administration that these forces are
able to exert tremendous influence on
Trump okay and the evidence is one Trump
withdrew from the Iran nuclear deal that
would have secured peace between United
States and Iran okay Trump moved the
United States Embassy from T aiv to
Jerusalem in Israel which um was a
major um which caused major friction in
the Middle East okay we also know that
um Trump ignore the fact that NBS
killed a
journalist okay so we also know that
Trump um has been very friendly with
Saudi Arabia we also know that Trump
sponsored the Abraham Accords which is
trying to bring peace between Israel and
other Arab countries and unite them
against Iran okay the last thing that
Trump did which is the most important is
that in January 2020 Trump ordered the
assassination of General Kasam salamani
who who is the leader of the
Revolutionary sorry who is the leader of
the Iranian Refuge
guards okay so from all this we can
suspect that a second in a second Trump
term uh war with Iran will be a major
priority
so is this clear so far all right now we
also discussed that okay even though
there are there are these forces that
want war with
Iran ultimately it is the US military
that must implement this war and if the
US military refuses to go to war then
the war can't happen so we discussed
that unfortunately the US military is
very different from what it was 30 years
ago okay 30 years ago
the US military maintain very standard
military Doctrine okay they maintain
three very important principles that all
militaries must maintain in a time of
war the first is mass
forces uh B is um avoid encirclement
right and the third is protect supply
lines
now the the important idea is that when
you fight a war like this okay which is
traditional Warfare you must have the
consent of the public okay because it is
the public that sends soldiers that
provides money that gives you political
support but in 2003 the US military
changed its mil Doctrine to one of shock
and all okay and what shock and all
means is that
you don't have to follow these three
principles anymore you can use ear
Supremacy um you you also have
technological
omniscience and you also have special
forces and this allows you to fight Wars
cheaply quickly and decisively so that
you no longer need public political
support for fighting Wars and as we also
discussed this created the idea of
hubris
in the American Military so the American
Military because of the 2003 uh war in
Iraq are clothin that can win any War
any place against any
enemy we know that this Doctrine is
actually not true and we know because of
something called operation Prosperity
Guardian okay so um a few months ago The
Who
which are a rebel group in in Yemen they
started to attack ships in the Red Sea
okay um and a lot of trade goes through
the Red Sea so the American Military
dispatched a massive Naval Force against
the
houthis were the Americans able to
defeat the
houthis no they were
not and so what the what what what are
the Americans going to do about it
what can they do about the
houthis what's what's the solution to
this problem you have these Pirates
houthis going around and attacking these
uh ships which is affecting um
International Commerce and that's why
inflation is such a huge problem right
now in the world so what are the what's
American Military going to do about
this what can they do about
this the answer is nothing okay the
American Military has no solution why
because they don't have the forces
necessary in order to undertake an
operation against the houthis they have
special forces they have Air Supremacy
they have technological omnicient
satellites but they don't have infantry
they don't have lots and lots of ships
therefore they cannot stop the houthis
okay and what's willing point is that
Joe Biden has come out and said that yes
we know we are losing the war in the Red
Sea and yes we know that we cannot stop
the houthis but we are going to
continue on this
path okay does that make sense this is
the idea of
hubris not knowing your limitations and
when when you are faced with your
limitations you refuse to accept your
limitations okay and that's why when the
US military is given the order to invade
Iran they'll probably go along with it
because they cannot imagine the
possibility that they could be defeated
in
Iran okay and then you have the
Iran
revolutionary uh core okay the re rol
guard and as we discussed last class
they want war with the United States
because
um they're very angry about us
interference in Iran right so during the
Sha regime which was a brutal police
state from 1953 and
19779 the Americans were the ones who
were backing this police
state so there are many who are who are
angry about this they're also um angry
about the fact that the US continues to
protect protect Israel and Saudi Arabia
okay and they're also angry about the
fact that that Trump killed J general
salamini okay um and as we discussed
it's possible that uh the rary guard
Corps killed last week the president of
Iran Ibraham Ry in or because um he was
preventing War okay so they want war
with the United States so you see the
map right you you see the logic of this
where there are power forces United
States pushing the United States towards
War you have Trump who has basically
agreed in its first term to raise or
increase escalation with Iran within the
Trump White House there be Jared Kushner
and Niki heli to push this war both
privately and
publicly the US
military um has so much huis that they
think they can win this war and Iran
wants to provoke the United States into
invading it okay United St Iran can have
many and for so Iran has many many um
strategies in order to provoke the
United States into war okay basically
United States is looking for a reason
and Iran wants to give them a reason and
that's why I think war between United
States and Iran is very likely in the
next two to four
years okay any questions so far are we
clear about where we are so far be
before I I move on
any questions okay so now let's talk
about the actual War so here most of
this is speculation okay but um I'm
using speculation in order to help us
better understand what a war would look
like okay so let's pretend that it's
March
2027 okay and Trump go on TV he
announces operation Iranian Freedom a
fullscale US invasion of Iran along with
Israel Saudi Arabia as its main Partners
but United Kingdom UK will be involved
Australia will be involved UAE will be
involved Poland will be
involved okay so you have many countries
attacking um Iran together and Trump
goes on TV and explains to the American
public why the United States is fighting
this war okay and this is what Trump
says first he says that for the past
year there have been violent protests in
Iran you have religious protests you
have political protests you have ethnic
protests the Iranian people are sick of
the Ayatollah they are sick of the
dictatorship they want democracy they
want want freedom and response the reg
guard are killing thousands of
protesters Iran is on the brink of Civil
War therefore the United States has an
obligation to
protect the people of Iran okay the
people of Iran are praying for freedom
and democracy in the United States the
world's greatest democracy must give
them democracy okay so the first reason
is free freedom and
democracy
second us intelligence along with
Israeli intelligence have discovered
that for the past two years Iran has
been working very very hard on
developing a nuclear bomb in fact Iran
is only one month away from having three
nuclear
bombs so that New York City San
Francisco and Los Angeles at Los Angeles
could all be
destroyed okay so to prevent this we
must strike first to stop Iran's nuclear
program
okay
third Iranian proxies the houthis hollah
many groups have been
disrupting shipping
in the Middle East in both the Red Sea
and the sh of
hus 40% of the world's oil passes
through that region mainly to East Asia
China Japan South
Korea our Global Prosperity is at stake
we must go to war to protect these
shipping lanes and ensure that the oil
goes to China Japan and South Korea so
that they can continue their economic
Prosperity so
the United States as the world hedgemon
has a responsibility to protect Global
Prosperity
okay
four Iran has been launching attacks
against our allies Saudi Arabia and
Israel hesah has been violent attacking
Israel killing dozens of Israelis in a
and
Israelis the huies have been attacking
Saudi Arabia oil fields damaging the
economy we have an obligation to protect
our allies our friends in the Middle
East
okay and the last reason is we know for
a fact that the Iranian ref guard Corp
is a
sponsor of
terrorism last week in a mall
there were gunmen who went and killed
107 people our intelligence says that it
was most definitely an Iranian
operation okay so for these five
reasons we have decided to invade
Iran but don't
worry this Invasion will be
successful because we have a lot of
allies the
UK Israel Saudi Arabia our friends we
part of this
operation our special forces are already
in the
country looking for their air bases and
their missiles we can knock them out at
the beginning of the war also we have
been in contact with Iranian opposition
groups they want to overthrow the regime
and when we help them they will install
democracy in the country our American
Military is the greatest in the
world in 1991 our military defeated
Saddam Hussein in 100 100
hours in 2003 our military defeated s
Hussein in only in less than three
weeks to prove that we are the greatest
in the world we will defeat Iran in only
two weeks
so do not
worry we will be strong in protecting
democracy freedom and Global
Prosperity okay so that's what that's
what Donald Trump will say to the people
of the United States okay and of course
you're going to have large scale
protests throughout the country opposing
this war but most people in the country
will support
this war okay all right so after this
speech the operation is
launched and on TV we'll watch this on
TV and the internet together on YouTube
together okay and we'll be so impressed
by the power of the US
military um this is
Iran this is the straight of
humus Saudi
Arabia um Israel is
here Red Sea is here Iraq is here okay
so in the hus comes the USS Gerald art
Ford it is a$1 13 billion super carrier
okay this thing is designed to destroy
countries it is now Pro
prowling the shus to ensure that
shipping is safe
America establishes ear Supremacy very
quickly okay meaning that it has
complete control over the skies nothing
can move in the skies without America uh
detection okay and then a massive
Invasion force is sent to Iran in the
South
100,000 US troops land maybe 200,000
Saudi Arabia troops land okay maybe you
have 300,000 to half a million troops in
Iran and they are about to strike
Tan in the north okay so in the South
the United States and its allies have
established a foothold they have a huge
presence in the country and they're
about to attack Tran okay all right do
you understand what what has
happened okay now I want to ask you this
question at this point I think the war
has been
decided who has won the
war America has established Air
Supremacy it controls the
skies US Navy controls the Seas you have
100,000 US troops in country ready to
stri
Tran the war has been decided who has
won the
war okay okay obviously this is a trick
question obviously Iran has won the war
why
why what's the problem with this plan
okay this is typical American Doctrine
shocking all this is how they fight Wars
but there's a problem with this plan
what is
it why would the Iranians want this
okay let's go back to traditional
military Doctrine okay in traditional
military Doctrine you have three
principles right Mass forces avoid
encirclement protect supply lines okay
these are three three things you must
absolutely obey if you are win to war
okay so using traditional mil military
Doctrine explain to me why United States
has lost the war right
now exactly first of all they're in
circle okay do you know why because Iran
are all mountains it's a
fortress okay meaning that to get these
troops into the country you have to
eardrop
them right but
guys once they're in the country you
can't get them out of the country you
understand okay so that's a first
problem they've been in circle right
what's the second
problem why
not that's right and why
else yeah that that that that's right
okay um so they failed to mass forces
okay Iran is a population of 90 million
people you will need at least 3 to four
million soldiers to even think about
conquering the country they've got
100,000 in this country okay and as Jack
says you can't move tanks through
Mountains they're not designed for
Mountain Warfare what are you going to
do okay so they can't mask forces and
they can't and they've been en circled
and and what else is a
problem and this is the biggest
problem exactly they cannot be
resupplied okay they have no supply
lines for them to be resupplied
airplanes have to drop ammunition food
into the country but again Iran is all
mountains so it's very easy for Iranians
to shoot down the airplanes does that
make sense when you pass through
mountains you can't see what's on the
ground a guy a random guy with a rocket
launcher can just shoot down the
helicopter okay which is what the what
the Afghans did against the Soviets in
the Afghanistan war and that's why the
Soviets lost the war
War a drone can take down any airplanes
okay so in other
words these guys are
trapped that you think they're soldiers
but they're not what they really are
hostages
okay does that make sense you have too
many people in the country so you can't
get them out of the country but you
don't have enough people to actually
launch a strike against tan you can't
resupply them and they've been encircled
by Iranian
forces all right does that make
sense okay okay now the logic of having
100,000 US troops in the country is that
once in the country all the resistance
to the regime will rise up and strike
against tan the Iranian Army will mut
will Mutiny against the country okay
that's the hope why do we think this
won't
happen why won't the Iranians revolt
against their
government why don't they want to
revolt that's right okay so Iranians
hate Americans okay remember that
Iranians remember the Sha from 1953
until 1979 the shaw the American
supported Shaw was running a a brutal
police state so brutal that everyone in
Iran revolted against the regime okay
that's number one what what why else
would the Iranians not support the
Americans
why that's the first
reason Iran has a bad history of America
what else
guys which country's next
door what happened in
Iraq America destroyed Iraq right from
2003 in 2011 America was there
destroying the country America said that
it would bring freedom freedom democracy
it would bring Prosperity it would bring
wealth but instead it just destroyed the
country American soldiers were running
into houses every night pointing guns at
children destroying homes and arresting
men for no reason okay Iranians saw all
this on TV they heard about all this
from Neighbors okay so they know that if
America comes it's destroy the country
not to bring freedom democracy not to
bring prosperity it's to destroy the
country that's why they're going to
fight okay
um and another reason is
that
Iranians think that they belong to a
great civilization so they value their
freedom and Independence okay does that
make sense they're not going to submit
to a foreign conqueror
so
um why else would the Iranians
resist okay also religion right the
Iranians are Rel religious they believe
that
um that s America is Satan and they have
a duty a religious obligation to fight
Satan okay so for many reasons there's
is no way that Iran people are going to
stand with America you might have a
minority but most are are going to
resist
okay okay so does that make sense okay
any questions so far
okay so uh that's a great question why
would the Americans think that thean
people will rise up and the answer is
that they need to justify The
Invasion does that make sense they they
have to have a logical explanation for
why this Invasion will succeed because
one other the criticisms against them
will be like you need 4 million people
to invade Iran they don't have 4 million
soldiers they have at most one million
soldiers okay total throughout the
world uh they have about 60,000 in the
Middle East so they can't get a million
soldiers so their only explanation is
okay well we're going to pretend that
once we invade the people of Iran will
support us do you understand so it's not
based on truth but but it's it's a
explanation for why the The Invasion
will
succeed does that make sense
oh you know that's a great question okay
so that's their propaganda but do they
actually believe this and the answer is
um hubris okay they do believe this
because they have hubris and and again
um it's hard because we're not in your
position but once you're in that
position where you have access to
nuclear weapons when you can kill anyone
in the world when you can see everything
in the world um it makes you think
you're God
okay and we we we remember like last
semester we were reading the Greeks the
Greeks believe the worst thing is
hubris because it makes you think you're
God but you're not God and you're gonna
get into a lot of trouble if you think
you're God okay does that make sense
okay all right any more
questions Okay so
um Trump says that Iran is one month
from developing a nuclear bomb right
America's been seeing this for the past
10 years okay you just Google this and
America's like oh Iran is only one month
away from a nuclear bomb they've been
saying this for the past 10 years so do
you understand when Trump gives a speech
there's absolutely no evidence that any
of this is true okay but this is how
he'll explain the
invasion okay all right and chances are
that even if
tan uh possess a nuclear bomb they won't
use it why
not that's right um the reality is that
there's only one way that America can
win this war against Iran okay they can
just nuke the country and America will
do that I if it has enough if it has a
pre-ex okay so nuclear weapons is
something that Iran is very afraid of
okay so does it make sense all right
so this becomes so American soldiers are
trapped in this
country okay so now the question then is
wait a minute here why would America do
something so stupid as send 100,000
soldiers into the country for no reason
and get them
trapped okay so that's a question
and what I want to do now is make you
the argument that um there are two ways
that we
can prove or provide evidence that this
is true okay the first is historical
analysis historical analysis means that
are there historical examples like this
okay are there historical analogues if
there are then this could be true okay
the second uh method is for Game Theory
analysis why would the actors who are
rational do something as stupid as trap
100,000 American soldiers in Iran all
right so we'll first do historical
analysis to find Historical analoges
examples s of similar similar to this
and then we'll look at Game Theory to to
try to reason out the motivation of the
actors okay so let's first look at Game
Theory oh sorry sorry let's first look
at historical analysis okay
so the year is
415 BC okay in
Athens remember that we studied
faciiities the pelan war last semester
okay so so we will now discuss the
pelian war the war is four the year is
415 BC and for the past um 17 years
Athens have been fighting a brutal war
against Sparta okay it's a
stalemate and then for whatever
reason um a man named alab alabes okay
has a suggestion and his suggestion is
to win the war against Sparta let's go
invade
sisily and uh
Nas his
opponent is like why the hell would we
want to invade Sicily it's far way and
alabed by this is like well because it
has a lot of money and if we invade the
country we can take their money okay and
it turned out by making this argument
the people of Athens really support this
argument okay they because the reason
why is war was costing them a lot of
money and they become addicted to the
Easy Money of Empire okay so they wanted
to fight this war so
nus has this great idea of how to
convince people not to go to war
okay and what he says to the people is
okay guys I know you want to fight this
War I know I know you want to I know
that you think this war is a good idea
but Sicily is a huge place it has a
Navy therefore we need a massive
Expedition Force against Syracuse and
Sicily okay we need at least 5,000
soldiers that's a lot okay because the
total Athan population is about 50,000
people okay 5,000 soldiers is a lot for
Athens and we need about 100 ships and
the idea is nus is trying to scare
people into not agreeing to not fight
okay that's the idea the Athenians say
that's a great idea let's send a massive
Force against Sicily and Syracuse so the
war can be can be won just like that
okay shock and
all so they so the problem though is
that never before in his history has
Athens sent a large Expedition Force
against another Power okay does that
make sense when the Persians invaded
they were invading Athens Athens didn't
go invade
Persia so when you have S a massive
Expedition Force against another country
what is your number one
problem what is the thing that you must
resolve for the Athenians really think
about it because he had actually no
experience in fighting a foreign
war okay uh so yeah so the other the
enemy knows the terrain better than you
do okay but there's actually a much
bigger problem than that and it is
what okay the biggest problem is
resupply and this is something that the
aans didn't think about because they
never thought they they never fought a
war like this before okay so they sent
this huge Expedition against Sicily and
Syracuse um which was a naval power were
surprised because they were like why
would the Athenians want to invade us
okay so for the first year the phans
were
destroying uh the Syracuse Army and the
Syracuse Army had to retreat back into
their City okay and so the f is late
Siege to
the city the Athenians Syracuse is here
the Athenians are here and the Athenians
control the sea
right okay so this situation is very
similar to this situation okay do you
understand but then what happened was
that the Athenians couldn't resupply
themselves the reason why is Syracuse
had also had a navy and they could stop
the aian Navy from resupplying the
Athenian troops and
therefore the Athenian Army was wiped
out in Sicily and this caus the
Athenians to ultimately lose the war
against Sparta and it caused the
Athenian Empire to
collapse okay do you understand and
again historians have been trying to
figure out for a long time why the
Athenians would do such a stupid thing
as as as to send a huge Army against
Syracuse because the risk of failure
here was
catastrophic okay and the only answer is
well the
Athenians had hubis okay they never
really lost a
war and they had become addicted to
Empire which is the same situation
America finds itself in today okay does
that make sense guys all
right so this has happened before in
history when the Athenians invaded
Sicily and lost to Syracuse their entire
Army was wiped out in Syracuse okay
because they couldn't resupply their
army does that make sense all right the
second example we can look at is the
Vietnam
War so in in the beginning of 1960 okay
in the beginning of the decade most
Americans have never heard of a country
called
Vietnam okay most Americans didn't know
what it was didn't know where it was
okay by the end of the decade in
1969 half a
million American soldiers were in the
country destroying everything okay but
also getting destroyed themselves
58,000 US soldiers died in
Vietnam so the question then is how this
happen why would this happen 1960
Vietnam was a distant country no one's
ever heard of by by the end of the
decade half a million US soldiers were
in country fighing this war against an
enemy they really didn't know okay in
1971 um the Pentagon papers came
out and the Pentagon papers uh was a
history of America's involvement in the
Vietnam War dating back to 1950s okay
and it made three major points the first
point is that
American leadership military leadership
has been expanding the war in
Vietnam without public knowledge okay
this is what we call Mission
creep so maybe at first they sent some
observers to the country then they sent
some advisors then trainers then
soldiers okay so Mission creep slowly
over
time um things escalate and you don't
understand why things escalate but they
do
okay second point is that American
leadership from very early on knew the
war was
unwinable this was the greatest military
in the world they dropped more bombs in
Vietnam in the
60s than all bombs were dropped in World
War II
okay and they could not win the war the
reason why is to win a war you have to
solve three problems okay okay the first
problem
is playar strategy
okay what are you trying to accomplish
in this
country what are your clear military
objectives okay second
is you must adopt to the battlefield
okay because all your best plans will
change over the course of battle okay so
the the the adversary that is most
willing to adapt to the battlefield will
win Okay the third thing is the will to
fight so if you want to look at a war
and who's most likely to win the war you
ask these three questions one does this
guy have clear military objectives that
everyone understands because that will
determine strategy okay second is is
this guy a adapting to the
battlefield the third is is this
guy um this does this guy still have the
will to fight and if the answer is yes
all three questions then the person will
most likely win the war okay and if you
look at the Vietnam War even
though America was killing a lot of
people it killed three million
Vietnamese during the course of the war
it was not destroying the enemy's will
to fight in fact it was making them
angrier and therefore more people people
willing to fight the
Americans okay so from a very so very
early on the American political
leadership knew the war could not be won
so then the question then is why did
America stay in the war and the answer
is
credibility
okay credibility just means they didn't
want to lose face they didn't want to be
laughed at by the Chinese and by the
Soviets
and by the Europeans okay but there's
actually another uh way to understand
credibility and it's it's what we call
the
sunk cost
fallacy okay have you guys heard of the
fallacy and the idea
is never ever go into a casino the
reason why is that when you go to the
casino you start losing money at some
point you cannot leave the casino why
not exactly you want to you want to
reclaim the money you've lost okay
you've invested so much that you cannot
leave you have to get that money back
and that's a problem with war eventually
you've invested so much you cannot leave
the war and that's what happened in
Vietnam America invested so much it can
it didn't want to leave the war because
it did not want to admit that all this
um has been lost okay it's what we call
the sunk cause fallacy that's
why even though America could not win
the war it still want to fight the
war okay does that make sense okay so
the Vietnam war is another
example okay that is similar to to
this where America invests enough
soldiers that it refuses to leave the
war and Aid defeat okay does that make
sense guys all right now let's look at
one more example and this is the uh most
recent example and it's the Russian
Ukraine war now as you know in February
2022 Putin ordered uh a special military
operation against
Ukraine okay and uh this is
Ukraine and Russia attacked from three
axises okay the North to take K the
capital you have the East to take
dones and then you have the south from
from uh Crea to take the South okay and
as we know uh the north fail okay the
north attack failed and the Russians had
to turn back but the
East and the South was successful okay
now let's think about this you have an
extremely powerful military attacking
your country the Ukraine
if you were the Ukrainian president if
you were the Ukrainian military there's
really only one way you can fight this
war and when and what is it using
traditional military Doctrine what how
much you fight this war you guys
know let's go back to mass forces avoid
in circle men protect supply lines how
much you fight this war there's only one
way you you you can fight this war
excuse
me how do you disrupt supply
lines there's only one way you can fight
this war and win and what is
it the the enemy is attacking you right
so what what must you
do okay the answer is you must
Retreat okay
why the enem is attacking right so you
pull back your forces
why would you do that what's the logic
of
that exactly okay it's it's as simple
okay you want to overextend your enemy
Ukraine is a huge country right and and
Russia didn't send send that that that
many soldiers maybe 160,000 that's not
that many soldiers so if you just give
them space they're going to outrun the
supply lines okay and then when they
outrun their supply lines you can
encircle them and you can disrupt their
supply and that's the only way you can
win the war okay what did the ukrainians
do
instead that's the only way to win this
war but what did what did the ukrainians
do instead which made them lose the
war yeah so the ukrainians refuse to
give up give up space okay they refuse
to give up land they want to fight the
Russians for every inch of
territory and eventually because the
Russians had more forces Mass forces
they were able to push push through okay
so that's the first major mistake that
Ukraine
made but then last
summer Ukraine launched something called
a counter offensive right so once Russia
was able to take space it it because and
because Russia is a land Army it started
to De to develop um fortifications
defenses okay mainly artillery that
three lines of defenses and in the
summer
offensive the Ukrainian military for
whatever reason sent tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of soldiers
against the this artillery and the
Russians blew every everyone up
okay now here's a
question why are the ukrainians doing
this they've lost the war now right they
have no more soldiers right now the
average age of the Ukrainian Army is
about it's over 40 years old they have
guys from their 60s and 70s fighting in
the military they don't have enough
manpower the war is
lost why would the ukrainians do do this
first of all why would they fight for
every inch of territory and why would
they launch a counter offensive against
a superior enemy a superior
enemy what's a
problem okay the first
is the president
zalinski the guy a TV actor okay which
means that he doesn't think strategy he
just thinks what looks good on
TV so for the first two years of the war
we're watching this on TV right it
looked as though the ukrainians were
going to win this
war right it I remember like two years
ago people were saying that the
ukrainians are going to march to Moscow
and overthrow Putin people are saying
that okay and the reason why is that
zilinski is is a master of Public Image
manipulation okay he was distorting
reality for people through
television the problem with that though
is it's not reality guys okay reality
the reality on the ground is very
different from TV okay so who else is
like zilinsky in this world Trump is
exactly like uh zilinski okay do you
understand Trump is also concerned about
what looks good on TV he's like I must
look
strong we must look as though we're
winning this war he doesn't really care
about strategy okay so because of this
it's very likely that he orders a land
invasion of Iran because it would look
good on TV okay so the problem with
zinsky is he cared about what looked
good as opposed to actually what
actually worked okay but you also have
other problems like you have
extremists in the Ukrainian military
okay and guys uh these extremists
they're Nazis they're
neo-nazis and so um the traditional
understanding of Neo of Nazis are people
who kill Jews okay but the Russians
don't understand Nazis that way because
because remember Germany and and the
Soviet Union fought fought this
War so the Russians understood Nazis to
be enemies of Russia who want to kill
Russians and there were many neo-nazis
in Ukraine they hate Russia they wanted
to kill as many Russians as
possible okay and they're they're the
ones who are pushing for as much War as
possible okay so you have these
extremists in the Ukrainian
military the last reason is
NATO so it's an Open Secret that NATO is
helping the Ukraine Ukrainian military
against Russia you have NATO military
advisors devising strategy against
Russia okay so it's most likely that the
summer offensive last uh last summer was
a NATO plan and not a Ukrainian plan
it's possible we also know that NATO
special forces are in the country
directing missile strikes against
Russian forces
okay which means
what if if this is true and
if um Ukraine loses the war meaning that
it doesn't have enough soldiers to
continue to fight this war what will
NATO
do yeah yeah I mean according to what
happened to Vietnam War and uh the
Athenians uh Expedition against Sicily
it is most ly that the most likely
outcome will be that NATO sends its own
troops against
Russia okay so macron of France have
said that we are we want to send French
soldiers and the British um prime
minister has said that he is considering
conscription for British people okay
which means that young British uh
citizens will be drafted into the army
to fight Russia
all right so these are three historical
examples that are very similar to what
could happen in Iran okay does that make
sense
guys all right any questions before I
continue all right is this clear so far
all
right now let's use another mode of
analysis called game analysis okay and
this is what I've been teaching you uh
this uh semester and the idea is that
Society what happens in the real world
is a game among human
beings okay so so and each person is
trying to play this game as to optimize
the outcome for that
person okay so the question then
is why would the United States send
100,000 troops into Iran so let's look
at the individual motivations of the
individual players okay so you have the
United
States what does the United States want
to
do what what what what does it want to
do by by doing
one and accomplishing
one it wants to top of the regime in in
tran right and you can only do that for
a ground Invasion okay okay so the
United States is trying to topple
Iran but then you also have other actors
okay
so um Iran what does Iran want to
do what what does Iran want to
do or the basically the Revolutionary G
Corp what do they want to
do ex me they want to kill as many
Americans as possible okay you
understand they want to force an
American Landing Invasion okay so Iran
wants to force a US invasion knowing
that if the US invades it has to lose
the war okay it will lose the war
because the re guard can just send
suicide bombers against the United
States okay now let's look at
Israel okay we know that the United
States wants to top of Iran we know that
Iran wants to force a US invasion to
defeat the the the Americans to
humiliate the Americans and and um exact
revenge for what happened in the past
okay what does Israel want to do what is
is Israel's optimal outcome you guys
know if you're Israel what do you want
to
happen Okay so you you you want Iran
defeated okay and then what do you want
to happen you want Iran defeated you
want the prox defeated and then what
what do you want to
happen do you want the United States to
stay in the Middle
East what happens if United States what
happens if United States and Iran both
lose the war mean Iran is destroyed as a
country the United States is destroyed
as a military presence in the Middle
East what would
happen Israel becomes the top dog in the
Middle East do you understand okay
Israel can now control the entire Middle
East so the timal outcome for Israel is
Iran and United States are both
destroyed okay you understand how about
how about Saudi Arabia what is their
optimal optimal outcome
exactly the same as isual exactly okay
do you
understand okay which will leave the
Middle East to Saudi Arabia and Israel
but Israel is a far superior military
than Saudi Arabia okay remember like
it's very easy to blow up Saudi Arabia
they have oil fields okay not that hard
not that easy to blow um Israel so
Israel becomes a top dog you understand
game theory in other words all the major
participants want an
invasion of
Iran okay but they want different
outcomes and Saudi Arabia in Israel most
benefit if this situation happens where
you have 100,000 US troops in the
country and they can't get out okay
because it becomes some cost fallacy
United States can only Point more
soldiers does that make sense all
right so is this clear to you guys okay
you can either use historical analysis
to get to this outcome but you can also
use Game Theory to get to this
outcome any questions so
far okay great okay so Seline asked the
most pival question
okay the United States has nuclear
weapons which is its ultimate trump card
right so what what Trump can say to Tran
is like I have 100,000 troops in country
you have to let them go or I will nuke
you okay you understand Trump trump can
say that listen I'm Trump I'm Donald
Trump I need to look strong I have
100,000 troops in the country I can't
get them out of the country so he says
to Teran you either let them go okay you
either gu guarantee him self safe
passage out of the country or I will
nuke
you right so that's what that that's
what will happen that is what Donald
Trump will do once the situation
arises the only way for Donald Trump to
say face is to threaten tan and says you
either let my my guys go or I will nuke
the entire
country
right so how does Tran get out of this
situation how do the Iranians protect
themselves against this possibility
because as because you're absolutely
right this is exactly what will happen
if this situation will arise Trump will
respond with nuclear weapons or a threat
of nuclear weapons so what must the
Iranians do to protect to protect
themselves against this
possibility who who can help the the
Iranians
now Russia okay do you understand so
before this war happens Iran and Russia
must come to an agreement where Putin
says from the out from from the onset no
one is allowed to use nuclear
weapons okay if Iran US US nuclear
weapons I will nuke Iran if the United
States use use nuclear weapons I will
nuke the United
States if Israel use nuclear weap I will
nuke Israel okay Putin if Putin says
that how will the world
react if Putin says this you are not
allowed to use nuclear weapons how will
the world
react he's a hero right he saved
Humanity but because he says this the
United States is now trapped
okay you understand and so this becomes
a black hole for the United States where
they can only send in more
troops they can't get any troops out
troops what's a problem with this what's
the problem sending more
troops no there's there's actually a
huge problem with this idea of sending
more troops what what is
it okay you can't like no one wants to
go fight you understand the military
cannot recruit
soldiers all right but even if you if
you did have enough
troops as Jack says you can't resupply
them
why why can't you actually resupply your
army why
not there but there's a bigger problem
than the supply lines what is it what do
you need to create bullets and
ammunition America has no manufacturing
capacity because America moved all its
manufa capacity to China okay remember
this so for every one ship that America
can build China can build 232 ships
that's what the Pentagon
says can do you
understand so if this were to were if
this war were to
happen there's absolutely no way America
can win this war it's just completely
trapped inside Iran and once it becomes
trapped some cost fallacy comes into
play and America just puts in all its
resources into the country but it's a
black hole okay they cannot use nuclear
weapons because Putin I said from the
from the onset you are not allowed to
use nuclear weapons
right but now the question then is why
would Putin do that right why would
Putin involve himself in this war and
that's what we'll discuss next class all
right how Putin sees this war and how
Putin will react in this war okay but um
before we end are there any questions
about any of this does this make sense
to you guys is this
clear any questions
oh that's a great question yeah um so
the the problem with Iraq is that Iraq
is an independent country you understand
there are 10,000 American soldiers in
Iraq
um so you would need you would need
their their permission even if you had
their permission there's a problem
problem here because there are lots of
Shia militia men in Iraq who are loyal
to Iraq okay and they would see the
American Invasion Force as something as
opportunity to attack the Americans okay
because they're still anger about the
Americans for what happened in Iraq but
even if they could have a staging area
in Iraq they still they still have to
deal with mountains okay do you
understand all right I mean the problem
is you have 100,000 troops in the
country you have to get out of the
country okay and it's very hard to get
get them out of the country if you go
through the mountains you're going to
get this you're going to get ambush in
the mountains if you go through the ear
th those drones are going to strike you
down that's that's the issue
okay right does that make sense okay any
more
questions okay great so uh on Friday
we'll talk about Putin okay